in-n-out burger
in-n-out burger from my former state of
california
is standing up against big government
so the government there is trying to
mandate
that customers in order to go buy their
cheeseburger
need to have the fauci algae
and plenty of people don't want the
fauci algae and for good reason
they might object to the fact that it's
made with
in development and in some cases
production with fetal stem cells they
might not like the fact that uh people
have died from the vaccine including
from blood clots so that's why they
pause the johnson johnson vaccine that
people have contracted nerve damage the
people have contracted myocarditis and
pericarditis one study out of uc davis
said that young men certain young men
might face greater risk from the from
the vaccine than from the virus itself
there are plenty of reasons
not to get the vaccine and so in and out
says we are this is a great line
we refuse
to become the vaccination police for any
government we fiercely disagree with any
government dictate that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business this is a clear government
overreach they believe it is quote
unreasonable invasive and unsafe to
force our restaurant associates to
segregate customers into those who may
be served and those who may not whether
based on the documentation they carry or
any other reason
damn right
damn right baby i love it this is good
stuff i'm so glad you like that clip but
stop hold up
ring that bell
yeah please you have to okay they don't
want you youtube does not want you to
get the notifications all the time okay
ring the bell subscribe head on over to
the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your podcasts
type it in m-i-c-h-a-l-k-w-l-e-s-s-h-o-w
fury
subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]